if there's one thing that we weren't
expecting from Mass Effect Andromeda it
has to be all the wonderful bugs and
glitches in the game we've come across
quite a few here but with the game being
so big there certainly be more to come
so subscribe to our YouTube channel for
even more Mass Effect videos writer
how to even start report State this time
it softens deadly storms that are
contaminated by radiation from the
scourge yes deployment was incomplete
due to environmental hazards and
ultimately hostile encounter it's an
aggressive move coming to iron my people
from the Milky Way were bold enough to
come to Andromeda I need to be at least
able to save them wonder what it's like
on EOS when it rains we do our job
some of me imagine cabin falling right
into that water
Liam I'm not right it just feeds off
hopeful comfort I hear you but this
isn't the time to lose our cool
well well glad you decided to show this
your handiwork ads the [ __ ] lutely
yeah
have a drink what is down drew hey now
the dream are you our wounded can wait
as long as you have something in mind if
the storm is the problem then let's
solve the problem we're talking about
weather and I have an idea about that
rendezvous with my coordinates will damn
he spotted me
[Music]
writer we can talk more later
sure
[Music]